hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es einen wunsch rezept und
zwar habe ich eine colaflasche gebacken
richtig cool oder das ist wirklich ein
echtes also eine essbare flasche
zwischen kuchen und zwar habe ich ja vor
kurzem die fanta schnitte gemacht und
dann hat mich ein foto r reicht von
einer colaflasche und ich sollte sie
nach backen oder habe ich einfach mal
geschaut im internet und zwar gibt es im
moment diesen trend dass man einfach
eine colaflasche packt da macht man sich
ein schokoladen hohlkörper und fühlt
daran den kuchen des seines belieben
sein
ich habe das jetzt auch gemacht bei mir
sitzt der unterschied dass ich jetzt
hier auch noch ein essbares etikett habe
denn oftmals war es einfach so dass das
original etikett einfach auf die torte
nochmal geklebt wird
aber das fand ich ein bisschen schade
weil man dann beim anschneiden der torte
das etikett wegnehmen muss und deswegen
habe ich jetzt hier auch ein essbares
etikett und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach
zugleich brauchen
ich sage jetzt zuerst diesen schokoladen
hohlkörper und für ihn dann später eben
mit einer torte
also los geht's oh jetzt zu starten
braucht ihr natürlich zuerst einmal eine
colaflasche wenn es geht eine leere
colaflasche und es war auch bei mir
eigentlich die erste führte denn ich
trinke nicht cola und wir haben auch
nicola daheim
deswegen hat mir die flasche gestern
gekauft und extra meine cousine
eingeladen das will er trinkt aber sind
glas leer getrunken
ich hab ich halt umgefüllt und es gibt
jetzt haushaltstipps mit cola ich
glaubte murat kann dann die feldern
damit sauber machen und ich kann zwar
schmecken putzen oder so auf jeden fall
werde ich das selber machen und damit
wir gleich den schokoladen hohlkörper
machen können brauchen wir natürlich
auch quartiere die habe ich jetzt hier
das sind 600 gramm
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier 400 gramm
hier 200 also zwei drittel ein drittel
denn ich werde gleich die kuvertüre
temperieren
ihr müsst die kuvertüre auch auf jeden
fall temperieren denn ansonsten bleibt
dieser schokoladen hohlkörper nicht fest
kann schneller schmelzen wird macht und
so einen grauschleier jetzt nehme ich
diese zwei drittel schokolade also
kuvertüre und lebt sie hier in ein
wasserbad ich hab jetzt unten den topf
mit warmem wasser habe es vorhin kurz
aufkochen lassen und jetzt ist der herd
grad aus aber ich werde ihn so auf
niedriger stufe stellen
das war's das soll jetzt nicht kochen
und da werde ich jetzt die zwei drittel
kuvertüre darin schmelzen
und weil sie jetzt eine küchenmaschine
habt die temporären kann also die
beheizbar ist können natürlich die
nehmen bei der tk gibt es zum beispiel
auch die beheizbaren schüssel mit
präziser temperatur kinder die auch
benutzen
ich finde das wort sagen so wird das
lasse ich jetzt hier kurz schmelzen bei
der flasche gibt es verschiedene
möglichkeiten um die aufzuschneiden und
zwar machen dass manche so dass jetzt
die flasche im ganzen lassen die
kuvertüre einfüllen diesen hohlkörper
hohlkörper erstellen und dann einfach
danach die flasche aufschneiden da sehe
ich die gefahr dass dann vielleicht
diese schokolade beim schneiden brechen
kann
deswegen steigt die flasche jetzt schon
auf klebt sie wieder zusammen mit tesa
und kann sie dann später einfacher weg
nehmen das nehme ich das etikett weg das
braucht ihr später noch da zeige ich
euch auch warum
und jetzt markiere ich mir zuerst bevor
ich sie auseinander schneider sondern
linie also zum beispiel hier damit ich
später beim zusammensetzen auch gleiche
da wo ich sie zusammen setzen muss und
jetzt schneidet ihr seht es hier auch
hier haben wir diese linie von der
colaflasche jetzt schneide ich an dieser
linie entlang
die
und bevor ich das jetzt hier komplett
weg schneide ich lebe ich erst mal die
hälfte zusammen dann haben wir nämlich
gleich einfacher dann braucht ihr auch
keinen der euch die flasche ist
zusammenhält
und jetzt schneide ich den rest noch aus
und klebt ihn jetzt auch wieder zusammen
würde das alles wahr macht und problem
wir sprechen aus erfahrung und wedelt
ist jetzt nicht komplett bühnen dich
zusammen geklebt hat ist nicht ganz
schlimm denn später kommt er da sowieso
das etikett drüber deswegen wird auch
die flasche an der stelle geschnitten so
die flasche kann ich jetzt mal flasche
sein lassen und nahm einer kubatur und
zwar ist die schon komplett aufgelöst
dies völlig aufgelöst die herzlich
kompletter ob ein paar kleine stückchen
sie noch drin da warte ich jetzt noch
ganz kurz und dann können wir die temp
die kuvertüre gleich temperieren mit der
methode und was die methode der impf
note sage ich dir gleich was das ist
die kuvertüre hat sich jetzt komplett
aufgelöst und die methode heißt sind
methode denn wir haben jetzt hier die
kuvertüre dies waren so etwa 40 grad
ich habe da auch so einem schoko
thermometer stecke ich da rein aber wenn
ihr kein tab ist es auch nicht schlimm
denn sobald sich die kuvertüre aufgelöst
hat sie etwa die temperatur 40 50 und
jetzt müssen wir sie wieder runter tun
denn die kuvertüre muss eine temperatur
von 31 grad haben damit sie später
einfach schön
festwirt den ganz hat und eben die
richtige temperatur hat denn das problem
ist bei kuvertüre wenn man die zu der
falschen temperatur verarbeitet dann
bekommt sie also dann
es gibt auch verschiedene kristalliner
zustände von schokolade und wenn es die
falsche form einnimmt dann schmilzt sie
euch schneller die wird marge die kriegt
diesen grauschleier und deswegen muss
man es eben temperieren
ich sehe das jetzt hier auch dinge gibt
es war also hier geht es auch gerade
temperatur moment so 54 habe ich jetzt
und jetzt gebe ich diese dieses
restliche drittel mit rein immer so ein
bisschen und rühre dass bis zur
schokolade dann auf 31 runterkommt aber
mit diesen zwei drittel ein drittel
könnt ihr das auch machen ohne
thermometer also dass ich wirklich fast
ganz genau und wenn sich die kuvertüre
dann drin aufgelöst hat diese feste
kuvertüre kühlpads die warme kuvertüre
runter und dann kommt die auf etwa 30 31
grad
und das ist die imb mit rot ich wollte
nicht schmeißen
also man sieht der zdk hat sich
aufgelöst ganz kleines stückchen sind
auch mit drin
deswegen setze ich es ganz kurz nummer
drauf so etwa eine halbe minute und dann
habt ihr wirklich die perfekte
temperatur bei mir zeigt es gerade 30,2
an
und sobald sich diese kleinen aufgelöst
haben haben wir wirklich die 31 grad
also distrikten phänomen und das thema
meisterschaft wenn ich aber mit nehmer
brauchst echt also metastudie das
richtig gut waren so dass die temperatur
nicht veräppeln ins netz und die stück
hier sind jetzt auch nur drin weil ich
vorhin die kuvertüre mich ganz klein
gehabt habe also wenn ihr sie ganz fein
hakt dann erledigt sich das von alleine
jetzt habe ich hier einen trichter mit
dem füllt sich es halt einfacher in die
flasche jetzt gebe ich die schokolade
oder die kuvertüre besser gesagt da rein
und die flasche muss natürlich vorher
ganz trocken sein also im ist die vorher
am besten noch bevor er die kuvertüre zu
verarbeitet einfach ein bisschen
trocknen lassen mit ich habe jetzt
gerade mit einem fön gemacht das hat
auch ganz gut geklappt aber du bist bald
darauf achten dass dafür nicht zu heiß
und die plastikflasche dann eben nicht
schmerzt
so ich schneide jetzt hier oben noch den
ring weg mit einem kater das hätte ich
jetzt auch vorher machen können wäre
jetzt nicht schmutzig geworden
und übrigens ging es im trichter ist
nicht ganz so gut weil einfach die
kuvertüre weise temperiert ist direkt
bei zimmertemperatur schon fest wird
deswegen habe ich sie direkt aus der
schüssel raus rein gefüllt so jetzt
kommt der deckel drauf
und jetzt müssen wir die kuvertüre gut
verteilen und ihr braucht auch 600 gramm
damit wir eine richtig schöne dicke
schicht haben denn wer weniger nehmt
dann haben wir einfach nicht genug
schokoladen schicht und dann ist es
einfach viel zu dünn ist immer gut
aufpassen dass es überall dran kommt
naja von die verschmierten hände
macht nix gerne es langsam
und jetzt muss die flasche erstmal in
den kühlschrank damit sie schön fest
wird da dreht ihr am besten ein bisschen
und was bei uns hat - temperatur hat um
genau zu sein minus fünf grad in dem ich
die flasche ziemlich jetzt an gerne auf
dem balkon und drei weiter dann wird sie
nämlich gleich fest war shop so kalt
aber man merkt schon dass uns fest wird
hatte ich mache foto oder wenn
ich meine wenn ihr die torte jetzt nicht
gerade mit dem winter machen wollt
können doch einfach akkupacks nehmen und
das einfach hin und her rollen
die flasche ist jetzt kalt ich hatte sie
jetzt noch im kühlschrank denn draußen
weil sehr gefroren und das möchte ich ja
nicht und jetzt habe ich hier auch noch
die zutaten für die füllung und kann
jetzt gleich die flasche eben
aufschneiden um dann auch gleich die
füllung zubereiten und zwar möchte ich
jetzt in die flasche ein tiramisu
einfüllen
ihr könnt natürlich auch was ganz
anderes einführen also ich habe jetzt
diese grundstruktur und können einen
fühlen was ihr möchtet ich habe es das
tiramisu gewählt weil ich dafür dann
nichts backen muss das heißt ich habe
einen no baic in flaschenform aber ihr
könnt zum beispiel auch in den
kuchenteig backen und den dann einfach
zurechtschneiden und da drin stapel mit
etwas creme
ich habe jetzt ein tiramisu ohne all das
ist das rezept von meinem egbert
tiramisu von diesem fruchtigen und zeigt
euch christi zutaten an zutaten brauchen
wir 150 millimeter starken kaffee tee
ist bereits abgekühlt
ein kilo mascarpone 400 gramm
schlagsahne 300 gramm magerquark etwas
vanille extrakt 150 gramm puderzucker
100 bis 150 gramm tiefgekühlte himbeeren
und ich brauche 100 bis 200 gramm
löffelbiskuits je nachdem wie viel wird
es eben bekommen so zuerst nehme ich
jetzt die flasche und öffnet das heißt
ich nehme hier das klebeband weg müssen
jetzt ganz vorsichtig arbeiten damit die
flasche jetzt nicht zerbricht
hier schneidet die flasche noch ein ganz
vorsichtig das jetzt ja auch nicht so
arg verkratzt
sonst habe ich die schokoladen form und
jetzt muss ich da natürlich eine öffnung
einschneiden denn ansonsten kann man die
flasche er gar nicht füllen oder suche
ich jetzt einfach die seite aus die ich
jetzt nicht oben haben möchte weil ich
drehte später einfach noch mal um das
habe ich hier ein messer in heißes
wasser getaucht und muss es jetzt rein
schneiden
bis heute ist echt mit heißen mit einem
heißen messer machen also praktisch
nicht schneiden sondern schmelzen
ihr schmerz euch jetzt voran
hier seht ihr jetzt übrigens mal wie
dick das ganze ist als head of horses
bisschen dünner hier hinten ein bisschen
dicker machte es auch nichts das brauche
ich jetzt auf jeden fall gleich noch zum
verschließen so die schoko colaflasche
hab ich jetzt mal weg gestellt und
bereitet schon mal die füllung zu und
dafür gebe ich jetzt mascarpone und
sahne in eine rührschüssel und kann das
gleich zusammen stören
so jetzt gebe ich ganz langsam die sahne
mit rein dann verbindet sich das auch
richtiges brot
und wenn sich so ein bisschen verbunden
hat gebe ich auch direkt puderzucker mit
rein und das war ne extrakt und auch den
quark und lass alles gut durchrühren
ich will jetzt die creme in einen
spritzbeutel mit ganz großer loch thüle
dann habe ich sie nicht einfacher das
ganze in die flasche einzufühlen und ihr
braucht am ende nicht ganz so viel creme
also wir werden die ganze creme
wahrscheinlich ähnlich verbrauchen aber
man weiß halt nie wie viel mehr
einfüllen muss und deswegen habe ich
jetzt einfach ein bisschen mehr gemacht
und da könnte einfach abstimmen wollte
ihr männerbild oder wollt ihr mehr creme
und dementsprechend könnte das dann zu
bereiten
jetzt fühle ich schon mal ein bisschen
creme ein bisserl gucken dass wir auch
nach hinten kommt
und jetzt traurig die löffel bist wird
in den kaffee und gebt ihr dann mit da
rein
die könnte auch bisschen rein drücken
dann verteilt sich die creme nämlich
noch ganz gut
jetzt nur bei himbeeren mit rein
jetzt mache ich das ganze einfach mit
creme und mit dem wechsel ist voll
und jetzt nehme ich den deckel da
streiche ich jetzt noch ein bisschen
kuvertüre drauf da hab ich einfach voran
die schüssel aufgehoben noch mal kurz
über das wasserbad gehängt und kann hier
die ränder damit einstreichen
jetzt setze ich den deckel einfach
wieder drauf und streich jetzt hier
überall noch etwas kuvertüre drauf
ich stelle jetzt ganz kurz in den
kühlschrank und kann in der zwischenzeit
mich schon mal um das etikett kümmern
die einfachste möglichkeit ist jetzt
natürlich einfach dieses etikett zu
nehmen
das sauber zu machen und das dann später
über die torte zu legen so machen dass
auch die meisten also habe ich im
internet nur gesehen
nur finde ich doch blöd wenn man die
torte dann an schneidet das man dann
einfach das etikett wieder wegnehmen
muss deswegen dachte ich mache ich jetzt
auch ein essbares etikett drum herum
nimmt das hier als vorlage und zwar
könnt ihr jetzt entweder vom tor
benutzen also rolf an land oder zum
beispiel modelliert schokolade und ich
habe mich jetzt wie von dort entschieden
wurde le chocolat schmeckt aber auch
sehr gut aber auch nähe
und ich nehme ich da einfach ein schönes
rot und werde jetzt erstmal so einen
großen streifen ausrollen
am besten lässt sich von damit übrigens
auch bäcker stärker ausfallen
und wählen das dann schön dünn habt
nehmt ihr das etikett als vorlage zum
schneiden
und jetzt nämlich weiße pulver farbe und
vermische die entweder könnte jetzt mit
alkohol vermischen oder zum beispiel mit
palmen was ihr vorher verflüssigt habt
alkohol fliegt etwas schneller und
trocknet schneller und es palm ihn
brauchen ein bisschen länger zum fest
werden so einfach ein bisschen
vermischen man kann man nämlich schön
damit mal und jetzt könnt ihr natürlich
auch etwas ganz anderes drauf schreiben
denn die colaflasche und das rote
etikett erkennt ja sowieso jeder
wir können jetzt auch zum beispiel happy
birthday oder irgendetwas anderes drauf
schreibt irgendwelche glückwünsche und
könnte es dann eben drauf malen ich
werde jetzt allerdings dass coca cola
das logo drauf mal
das etikett habe ich jetzt gemalt und
ich habe jetzt ein paar details mehr
gemacht als sie eigentlich vorhatte aber
ich bin so richtig gut
jetzt nehme ich die flasche und stellen
sie jetzt erstmal auf jetzt muss ich das
etikett drumherum kleben und das mache
ich jetzt mit einem zucker kleber und
den gibt's jetzt mittlerweile auch so zu
kaufen also so in natura finde ich
richtig klasse
denn dann kann man es richtig gut
portionieren also man muss nach vorne
einfach diese spitze wegschneiden und
jetzt kann ich einfach direkt mit dem
kleber daher gehen und auch punktuell
kleber auf tragen also ist wirklich
super man muss ich dir nicht mehr an
mich und ich brauche es auch gar nicht
so viel und der kleber besteht nur aus
zellulose kurve also das ist ein
komplett essbarer kleber
wahrscheinlich kann man sich auch die
zehner damit angeben
jetzt schaue ich dass der übergang hier
dass es hinten bleibt dann finde ich ja
nicht so schön möchten ihr verdecken und
nehmen das etikett hoch und kann das
jetzt ganz vorsichtig hier platzieren
und schneiden sie jetzt noch sauber weg
jetzt lebe ich noch mit etwas kuvertüre
den deckel an
dann nehme ich jetzt den originalen
deckel und bauten jetzt nicht aus.von
land nach weil ich muss er da hat die
torte nicht schneiden also man kann ihn
später einfach beim essen den deckel
wegnehmen und ist es das einfachste und
dekorateure habe ich in eine kleine tüte
gesteckt und habe sie noch mal kurz in
einem heißen topf gehalten mit heißem
wasser
jetzt gebe ich ein bisschen kuvertüre
drauf im moment vorher muss der ring
aufnehmen
die torte ist jetzt fertig war für etwa
drei stunden im kühlschrank und jetzt
können wir gleich anschneiden wie
sowieso machen recht.de in flaschen
wollen wir konnten warum machst du zu
haben so etwas kann nein natürlich nicht
ich finde es ist einfach ein cooler
klick auf jeder party ja so macht stellt
es einfach so hin
ich denke es gibt bestimmt den ein oder
anderen der auch nach der flasche
greifen möchte und dann eben max ist
eigentlich gar keine cola fans oder eine
tolle geht man gerade flasche so zum
anschneiden lege ich sie aber hin
man muss auch kein ego abholen können
auch jungs haben ja auch was anderes
nehmen
bei cola ist eben der vorteil dass ich
zeit bitterschokolade nehmen kann
ich könnte zum beispiel keine fanta
machen weil dann müsst ihr die
schokolade geld sein
so jetzt suchen wir eine schöne stelle
klar ich mache so zum anschneiden nimmt
jetzt immer ein heißes messer da habe
ich jetzt abgekochtes wasser und halte
es hier ein bisschen rein aber ihr müsst
es natürlich dann auch immer trocken
machen und dann die torte anschneiden
jetzt zerschnitten das ging jetzt
ziemlich schwer denn unten in der
flasche ist ja ganz viel schokolade und
deswegen musste das wirklich ganz
langsam machen und mit viel geduld ihr
habt jetzt hier gesehen hier ist ganz
viel schokolade desto zerschneiden war
natürlich ziemlich schwierig aber ich
wollte schneiden damit eben auch hübsch
aussieht darf jetzt probieren jawohl ich
finde auch als gag also wenn das jetzt
wirklich für eine party werfen
geburtstag wenn dies nicht mal so
schlimm dass einfach mit einem hammer zu
zertrümmern
das haben wir gekriegt auch ein stück
kommen schätzte ein stück schokolade
machst du kriegst das beste eine torte
die nicht nur gigantisch aussieht so
auch wunderbar schmeckt ganz ehrlich
meine da kann man nichts falsch machen
bei tiramisu in einem schokoladen mantel
denke ich kann man nichts falsch machen
ich würde mir jetzt noch auf dieses
stück etwas cacau streuen da hat man
noch mehr dieser ist ja diesen tiramisu
geschmack und ich finde es sich einfach
was echt cooles also auf jeden fall zum
nachmachen gedacht noch nicht super wenn
wir jetzt momentan kraft frische
erdbeeren wenn schon geerbt haben ja
definitiv also zu entwerfen können da
gerne das auch nicht mehr machen
und wenn ihr das nachmachen volt gibt es
das rezept auch sex - blog.de die
anleitung ist natürlich hier im video
und ja ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen gebacken wurzeln nicht und
bis zum nächsten mal
jetzt kannst du gar als fingerfood essen